on February 8 2018 a retired man living
in Suburban Georgia named Henry Norris
was watching the evening news in his
bedroom when he heard what sounded like
a bomb go off inside his house a team of
more than two dozen police officers had
set off flashbang grenades they broke
through every door of his home with
battering rams
Norris who was nearly 80 years old at
the time told the officers about his bad
knees and his heart condition One Cop
thrust him to the ground where the
police kept him for several minutes
they arrested him and took him out of
his house in handcuffs
the officers were doing a drug raid but
they had the wrong house the actual
suspect according to the warrant lived
in an off-white house with a black roof
Norris's house was yellow with a gray
roof and he didn't resemble the man
police Hereafter who was less than half
Norris's age
when Nora sued his lawsuit was thrown
out because of a legal Doctrine called
qualified immunity which makes it
difficult for victims to hold state or
local government employees accountable
for violating their constitutional
rights qualified immunity was first
created by the Supreme Court in 1967.
the court strengthened it in 1982 when
the justices ruled that a victim cannot
sue a state or local government employee
unless nearly identical misconduct has
been ruled unconstitutional in a prior
Court decision the rationale is that if
there isn't an existing case with almost
the exact same facts then how would
public officials know what they're doing
is wrong
I think you could compare it to you know
a person bringing a lawsuit that they've
slipped and fallen in a grocery store
and are filing a lawsuit and the court
says have you been able to find a prior
court case in which someone slipped and
fell on orange juice in the produce
aisle UCLA law professor Joanna Schwartz
is the author of the new book shielded
how the police became Untouchable
because if it was water in the dairy
section that's not enough because how
could a How could a grocery store
possibly know that they had to clean up
water from the produce orange juice from
the produce section based on prior
precedent that said they had to clean up
water from the dairy section qualified
immunity is supposed to ensure the
government employees have proper notice
of what conduct violates the
Constitution
but this assumes that police officers
were reading case law in their spare
time
I aimed to just to test that out and I
looked at hundreds of California
policies and trainings and found that
officers perhaps no surprise officers
aren't educated about the facts and
holdings of the cases that clearly
established the law there are hundreds
if not thousands of them they couldn't
possibly learn all of those cases in the
course of their limited training hours
qualified immunity applies even in cases
of straightforward police misconduct so
for example when Fresno California
police officers allegedly stole over 225
thousand dollars in 2013 while executing
a search warrant a Federal Court ruled
that they were still protected by
qualified immunity because they didn't
have quote clear notice that they were
violating their victims constitutional
rights
we as a society
whether we like it or not are providing
these officers with their power their
discretion their Badges and their guns
and I believe that we as a society also
have a responsibility a shared
responsibility
to
make those people whole
when their rights have been violated
under under our Authority and to try to
prevent something from happening again
in the future to underscore how
difficult it is to hold police
accountable Schwartz writes about Tony
Tempa a man who died during an arrest in
Dallas in 2016. Vicky timpa Tony's
mother
got a phone call uh in Dallas
that her son had died a call from a
police officer or police official
but had no information for Vicki about
how Tony died and she called the
department multiple times got different
stories about what had happened to Tony
that he had had a heart attack that he
had fallen down somewhere near his car
uh and no straight stories she then went
to the morgue to see him and and
discovered that there was
grass in his nose how is that possible
it turns out the Dallas Police
Department had intervened during a
mental health crisis Temple experience
one evening in August of 2016. officers
kneeled on us back for about 14 minutes
in violation of their own training and
he subsequently died of quote cocaine
and the stress associated with physical
restraint according to an autopsy
[Music]
is cool come on
I mean breakfast
waffles but Vicky temper didn't know
exactly what happened because the police
wouldn't tell her they refused to turn
over the body camera footage which she
needed to State what's called a
plausible claim the bare minimum
standard to file a federal lawsuit
against government actors if she
couldn't get more information on what
happened that night then her lawsuit
would be dead on arrival before a judge
could even evaluate whether those
officers would get qualified immunity
when they filed the lawsuit they didn't
know who the officers were
who had been at the scene and they
didn't know what happened to Tony so
they wrote sort of a bare bones
complaint that the Dallas Police
Department moved to dismiss because it
didn't State a plausible claim for
Relief even though the Dallas Police
Department had in their own possession
the body camera videos and other
information
about what had happened in the case
Vicki went through a three-year legal
battle which finally forced the police
to turn over the footage in August 2019.
only then did she have enough facts to
write that plausible claim the idea
about this plausible pleading standard
is to give defendants notice of what is
being alleged against them well the
Dallas Police Department had all the
notice in the world about what their
officers had done
and yet used this tool to try to get the
case dismissed
those Dallas police officers originally
received qualified immunity that was
ultimately overturned on an appeal and
the Supreme Court confirmed in 2022 The
Tempest family could finally sue the
police
but it took six years for Vicky temper
to get there the Supreme Court and state
and local governments across the country
have created barriers to relief in these
cases at every stage of the litigation
process that makes it very difficult to
win in these cases Justice Clarence
Thomas has critiqued qualified immunity
as an example of legislating From the
Bench while Justice Sonia Sotomayor has
said it allows police to quote shoot
first and think later but some consider
it necessary to protect relatively low
paid public employees who can't be too
afraid to make mistakes
policing is obviously a dangerous job it
is often low paid
how do we know that allowing officers to
be sued isn't going to provide yet
another disincentive to policing in the
first place the idea that's been
commonly stated that officers are going
to be bankrupted for Split Second
mistakes without qualified immunity
Bears no relationship to reality because
officers are virtually Always
indemnified by policy or law meaning the
employer pays for those settlements and
judgments and the fourth amendment
protects against those split-second
mistakes so they don't have those things
to be worried about so let's say we
adopt some of the reforms that you
propose
what's stopping Joe schmoe down the
street from sashaying into the federal
courthouse because he has snacks to
grind
and just filing a suit Joe schmoe can
sachet into the courthouse today and
file a lawsuit uh Joe schmoe with his
frivolous lawsuit is not going to be
able to find a lawyer I'm guessing part
of that is the way in which they are
paid for these cases they are paid if
they win usually a percentage a third of
the recovery
if they lose they're paid nothing and
these cases are far more complicated and
time-consuming and expensive to bring
than your average slip and fall case so
I've talked to a number of lawyers
who typically do take personal injury
cases or medical malpractice cases take
their first civil rights case invest
tens of thousands of dollars in their
time lose lose everything and think I'm
going to go back to my other line of
work where I'm more likely to be able to
make enough to keep the lights on so
you're saying a lawyer could spend
thousands of hours of his or her time
working on a case and get paid nothing
absolutely absolutely lawyers do with
regularity anytime a plaintiff's lawyer
brings a civil rights case that goes to
trial and they lose
they will get nothing for their time
overcoming qualified immunity doesn't
mean you've won your case it simply
gives you the right to take your claim
to trial and ask a jury to determine if
damages are deserved while qualified
immunity only applies to State and local
actors Federal cops receive an even more
robust set of protections and are
shielded by what essentially amounts to
Absolute immunity take the 2016 case of
a then 70 year old retired cop named
Jose Oliva who arrived for a dental
appointment at a VA hospital in El Paso
Texas when unprovoked according to
surveillance footage Federal officers
place them in a Chokehold and can
totally leave his hand behind his back
damaging his shoulder and requiring two
surgeries he was prohibited from suing
because the cops were acting at neither
the state nor local level these sorts of
abuses have put police under an intense
scrutiny over the last several years but
Schwartz concedes that law enforcement
conduct has improved in recent decades
one indication of that is that fatal
police shootings are down nationwide in
New York City for example officers shot
and killed an average of 62 people a
year from 1970 to 1974 which went down
to nine fatal shootings a year from 2015
to 2021. according to data compiled by
Peter moscow's a professor at the John
Jay College of Criminal Justice I do
think that policing has improved in in
important ways my inquiry with this book
is not to set out to Canvas all of the
ways in which policing should function
but really to ask the question of what
kind of justice is available to people
when their rights are violated it may be
that people's rights are violated less
frequently now than 10 or 20 years ago
we don't have comprehensive data but I
think everything that we do have
suggests that that that is likely true
but it remains true also that our
systems for holding police accountable
in those circumstances in which they
violate the law and people's rights
really fails to offer Justice to a
meaningful percentage of those people so
how do you respond to people that are
saying you know we essentially expect
police to be James Bond and just be the
perfect shot
I don't think that our legal rules
demand perfection
from officers and and I think it's it's
far from it
in situations where courts say that
there could be a constitutional
violation
there could be excessive force
ultimately again this is a question for
a jury to decide whether the force used
was reasonable there are many many
people whose names readers have never
heard of whose lives have been turned
upside down if not snuffed out by law
enforcement and then have their efforts
to seek Justice in these cases
uh denied I think that is a caseload and
a cost that we as a society should be
willing to take on this is the moment to
sit back calmly look at the information
look at all of the information and
design a better future